I try to jump rope every day.
I believe that it will help me grow faster.
You are tall enough.
I want to know a lot about space.
How many science books do we have?
Don't worry.
We have enough books.
Bill tries to run faster.
He wants to be the fastest!
He runs fast enough.
He runs 100 meters within 11 seconds.
Giraffe was very hungry, but doesn't want to eat leaves.
He tried to eat ants just like an anteater.
But ants bit his tongue, ouch, ouch, ouch!
He tried eating honey just like a bear.
But bees stung his nose, ouch, ouch, ouch!
He tried to eat fish just like an otter.
But he fell in the water and got very wet, oops!
Finally, he bit into the leaves hanging from the tree, yum, yum, yum!